[Music]
[Music]
nurture can be fate
and nature can be malleable
if only we could come up with secular
science
what we're saying is heritability is an
index
of educational opportunity
hello and welcome to how we became who
we are
now stressing the importance of heredity
is something generally associated with
the right
and focusing on environmental factors
with the left
yet many on the right care greatly about
environmental factors such as schooling
for their children
well those on the left want to describe
racists as evil
and not excuse their behavior on the
basis of how they were brought up
so to avoid this hypocrisy should we
excise politics
from the nature nurture debate should we
focus on the new data coming
from twin studies that identifies the
huge impact of heredity
on outcomes we've traditionally thought
environmental
or is this a dangerous theory with such
damaging consequences for society
that it shouldn't be given air time at
all well we've got a fantastic panel
lined up for you here today
matt ridley is the author of nature via
nurture
and genome and was previously the
science editor of the economist
jasmine alabai brown is a renowned
journalist whose work regularly appears
in newspapers such as the guardian the
times
the new york times and the mail and
robert ploman is an eminent psychologist
and geneticist
and author of blueprint how dna makes us
who we are now as you know we're going
to have
a pitch a three minute pitch from each
of the panelists
uh on the question should we excise
politics
from the nature nurture debate and i'm
going to start with you matt
thank you very much marianne uh and
should we excise politics from the
nature to bird
debate yes if we can but
i'm not hopeful in this highly polarized
world
i wrote a whole book as you said called
nature via nurture and the depressing
thing about that was that almost nobody
notices the middle word
um i still go on radio shows and people
say oh yes you wrote a book called
nature versus nurture and the book
sitting in front of them
so um it's it's it's a problem this um
trying to
be a brave for the middle ground yeah
talking of bravery if i say
brave new world to you what springs to
mind
well for most people a novel by
aldous huxley of a dystopia based on too
much
nature too much belief in heredity but
you know go back and read the book it's
not like that
it's actually a book about too much
nurture it's about children being
drugged from childhood in such a way
that they end up being different from
the others it's not about
innateness at all it's about nurture
very cruel nurture
and uh nurture can be just as cruel as
nature
show me hitler and mengele and i'll show
you stalin and lysenko
so the idea that nature and nurture are
alternatives
poisoned a lot of debates in the 20th
century and i hope it doesn't have to
poison debates in the 21st
because it is not a zero-sum thing it's
not a spectrum
from one to the other and it's not one
as an alternative to another
indeed as william james said right at
the start of the debate and i think i
wish we'd listen to this
more the more nurture you have the more
nature you
need to have it and vice versa
here's an example monkeys are not
innately afraid of snakes
a monkey born in the lab shown a snake
for the first time is not frightened of
it
but it's much easier to teach a monkey
fear of snakes
than to teach it fear of flowers and
this was the result of a brilliant
experiment by susan minnicker in which
she dubbed a video so that the monkey
saw another monkey being frightened of a
snake but
actually she'd put a flower over the
snake on the video so the
monkey thought the other monkey was
terrified of flowers and all it learnt
was that some monkeys are bonkers
the more we lift the lid on jeans the
more we find that they are actually
open to experience they take their cues
from what happens to us
if you remember this talk that i'm
giving right now
it will be because inside your brain
cells
genes are being switched on and off for
fractions of a second
to alter the strength of connections
between nerve cells to lay down a new
new memory
that's what genes are actually doing
they're often
literally turning on and off during our
lifetimes
and they're at the mercy of what happens
to us so
nurture can be fate and nature can be
malleable
and as marianne said the idea that the
left believes in nurture while the right
believes
in nature i think he's just plain
empirically wrong if you look at what
people actually do
because the left believes in tapping
talent among underprivileged people
finding the bright kid and giving her
opportunity
and that only makes sense if you believe
there are such things as bright
kids whereas the right only believes in
edu
the right believes in education and that
only makes sense
if you think nurture is necessary as
well as nature
or to put it more bluntly as someone
said to me professors are inclined to
attribute the intelligence of their
children to nature
and of their students to nurture
[Laughter]
okay so yasmin should we excise politics
for the nature nurture
debate yes i i absolutely think
um uh we should but of course it's not
going to be
it's not going to be happening is it
because everything
is connected to politics i i i was
thinking of a
of a of an example for me
if only we could come up with secular
science
a secular state where where you know
we've separated
religion and politics if we could
separate science from politics in the
same way
do you know what i mean that actually
make it impossible for politics to
influence
science the way it's done for such a
long time to secularize
science but increasingly i think
we see the opposite trend where politics
is infiltrating
almost everything um
and and and and politicizing this
particular debate has done no one any
good
not neither the left nor the right um
it it's i mean one thing i'd like to
know from the two experts later is
whether we are hardwired for example
to be left or right how is it that in
the same family
in my family my brother was incredibly
right wing and always was
and i was incredibly left-wing
you know i don't know where the hard
wiring begins but
so unsavory politics and politicians
will
always use um nature nurture
let me tell you what just in the last
um uh
three weeks these are the statements
i've had said to me
or emailed to me or on social media
indian these was actual statements
indians
learn fast but have no invention
cannot invent anything africans have
invented nothing
the poor the poor are evolving
out thank god middle class people
are born to be confused and will never
get anywhere now
we're listening to i'm hearing this in
the 21st
century uh how can that not be
utterly depressing i think we do need i
think both
both uh my fellow panelists
are absolutely right to talk into to try
and break this binary
to see it as stupid and dangerous but i
just fear that we've
that that that divide of left and right
and nature nurture even even had a
little argument in our household last
night
um because as soon as i started talking
about you know it's a bit of both
there are you know people who think no
once you start talking about it that's
dangerous
great so robert your pitch on whether we
should exercise politics from the nature
nurture debate
yes well i have a decidedly
old-fashioned view as a scientist
that as a scientist you try to be as
objective as possible
and not to let your values
enter into the work you do your work is
supposed to be replicable and
all of that i know a lot of people
disagree and increasingly
there's a group called science um uh
for the people the idea that you know
science should be driven
by what some people think ought to be
good for people i mean you know and
genetics is usually considered
not to be good for people but i think as
much as we can
keep the science separate from the
politics is good
politics involves policies and policies
are not necessarily related to
scientific information
you know i'll take the big one first
inheritability of learning ability
it is substantially heritable maybe
about 50 percent heritable
meaning individual differences between
children and how they learn
can be attributed substantially to
inherited dna differences
this is very different from what matt
and to some extent yasmine were talking
about with innateness
and what happens at the level of the
human species and how we evolve
99 of our 3 billion base pairs of dna
are the same
for all of us that's what makes us human
to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas